so the lobby briefing uh and the prime
minister's official spokesman was quite
long because we only have one a week
during parliamentary recess uh so people
really took the opportunity to ask a lot
of questions mainly about gaza
um there people were not aware that we
did actually report it over the weekend
that export licenses to israel are
aren't being reviewed obviously as they
come in they're done on a case-by-case
basis and what the government is now
checking is that any license that might
have been awarded say six months or a
year ago remains appropriate in what is
obviously a far worse situation than was
the case
in the not so distant past
but also a lot of questions on the issue
of restraint because we were told that
the prime minister has urged restraint
on both sides but specifically uh said
that there was a need for restraint in
conversations with his israeli
counterpart benjamin netanyahu
and so journalists were curious as to
whether or not he feels that that
restraint has been adequately observed
given that we're seeing civilian
casualties attacks on un schools and and
the like and their downing street didn't
want to get drawn in as you as you might
uh anticipate the danger of course is
that you can talk till you're blue in
the face about restraint but if nobody's
listening you end up looking rather
powerless
just one observation though would be
that uh david cameron in that respect is
in pretty good co pretty good company on
this territory